I've gone live put it down right now how
are we going to breathe out
I said hang on
Imagine Dragons
good evening good afternoon good morning
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel we have you know
Matthew with us say hello Matthew
hello we have Young Harris with us oh
my God Melvin who's new
hey
you have the greatest name I wish I was
called Melvin
James stupid name Melvin's awesome name
um
yeah exactly you've got cool name
damn you also my girls it can be a
girl's name as well and my brother found
a a boy's name a name thing once and it
said Jamie used to be a boy's name
but luckily Jamie Oliver thank you Jamie
Oliver
you can say Melvin because you can't say
sci-fi first
I'm Alvin howdy Andrew howdy Shelly
howdy Andrew batmouse in
um Paul Malone is in David Jerome is in
and loads and loads of others
um if you don't know Melvin
he appears in our comments regularly a
Sci-Fi Quest so give him a warm welcome
our comment section is going to be like
severely dry tonight
I've got to say if you don't know Melvin
you do
Jimmy J is also with us that's a good
name and kaha uh who's a member thank
you very much kaha welcome that sounds
like the name of gold
let's get on with it guys because we've
already got 45 people watching which is
amazing thank you so much just wanted 47
and they want to hear about what's going
on with Stargate do they I think so
um oh no I'm sorry Legally Blonde three
yeah apparently
is the name of the host
cool yeah that's very true and uh yeah
Mark's with us and uh John's with us and
J.R Casanova
um
already right so we know what's going on
this week guys yeah so we've had a bit
of a Mad week
um so it started off on Sunday night
with a source emailing me and Matt
saying
keep an eye on things stuff's happening
um message this other person who works
in marketing I message other person who
works in marketing and they told me that
their company had
um basically recommended to Amazon
as part of their consultancy thing that
they should anything they get anything
they've got ready to announce announce
it their basical argument was look all
the other Studios have come out of this
quite badly particularly Disney Netflix
and Warner Brothers even to a point have
come out of this really badly you've
pretty much quite a bit unscathed take
advantage right so that seemed to be
where the rumor then shot around all the
agents and things and because that was
it was somebody that works in agents
that told me actually I saw Matthew's
belly button there
um big news breaking news just saw
Matthews
um do we have a Graphic for that
yeah yeah we don't we don't need that
where's the spoilers thing
um so
it then moved on from that little bit
that I finally got in touch with the
person that my initial person told me oh
sorry
through that I then got in touch with
somebody that I actually do know that
works reasonably close to the pr
marketing internally to MGM and they
told me that they'd been ordered by
Executives to have a look at everything
that they've got planned for the next 12
months and um they needed to report by
the end of the week
so any any sort of ways they're planning
to Market things
all the pr that they've got planned for
them and they wanted a report done by
the end of this week which would be
Friday
oh great I've had a little bit of an
update on that though
so apparently that didn't include
Stargate
so apparently there is a plan
on how to
plan this it was planned to go to San
Diego Comic-Con
that was not included in the reports of
my sources in the reports today and
Stargate wasn't included
first of all that's the big that's the
first big bit of news
good thing a bad thing
I think I I don't think it's anything to
worry about Comic-Con wasn't that long
ago
so yeah it was July it was a junior if
they've already planned it yeah the
strikes happened they didn't know how
long they were in the last if the
strikes had lasted a year then they
probably would like to re-plan but
because it's it's been over relatively
quickly
they're just like yeah just just dust it
off and we'll just push it out
that's what I think
just nothing to be concerned about
yep
uh not for the sake of Devil's advocacy
I'm kind of like very neutral on that I
guess where it it it probably isn't
nothing Burger but also the way Studios
tend to plan things out or at least try
to have things planned out
if it wasn't on the docket for that it
would you would think it would be on the
docket on the next like poster standing
right next to it like all right well
this is gonna be like here instead of
here
maybe the strikes did delay that uh even
being put on a docket somewhere but
you'd think that somebody would have
some kind of semblance of of knowing
when it was wanting to be announced at
least so I don't know if that is great
well I there's an alternative okay
scenario here that I think we're we're
missing out a little bit it could be not
included because they've already done it
because it's already there's already a
plan in place that doesn't need
looking at again
with uh the Comic-Con thing they've
already done it it's already done
well I think because as soon as San
Diego Comic-Con went through I think
they came up with a plan B yeah and that
plan B is what is already in place for a
couple of things a couple of reasons
right
we've got
the release date of the original 1994
movie of Stargate is October 29th yes I
think that's a possibility that's a
that's a possibility
and I'm going to talk about why in a
minute but because I've had a long chat
with my PR person today who I have to
say doesn't actually work in the PR
department which is why she didn't they
could be he don't get to see everything
they get to see bits of things because
of what they do because they uh more no
I can't I can't say more but because of
what they do they only get to see bits
of what happens sort of thing so it's a
bit that gets to her they I'm just sort
of sheets [__] it there's 90 people in
my department probably
um
um so she gets to see the bits that come
to her and then they bounce back this is
the person that told us about when Bad
Robot pitched because they literally
was involved sort of thing
um so
anyway if there's a plan
it's not just though that October 29th
is
um when the 1994 movie came out which I
think would be they like these
anniversaries when they announce these
things don't they like it to be like
oh on this day 40 years ago
um the game comes out between now and
Christmas as well and that's supposed to
be in the next six weeks or so
wouldn't the game do better
if Amazon a week or two before announced
a movie or a series
oh Big Time 100 get the high part yeah
and then people to wet their appetites
go play the game yep definitely
but we've got one big problem
with all of these theories
yeah anybody want to take a stab and
guess what the one big problem with all
of these theories is legally blind three
it is exactly
yeah there's no problem there's no
problems the actor strike is the problem
okay okay okay it makes sense so right
they are
as of today meeting to discuss terms so
fingers crossed yeah yeah
like shortly after the writers strike
they were basically following suit now
the writers are off strike they're going
to follow suit again I can see it
yeah
straight away or was it like a few weeks
or a month later about two months after
so we're hoping that doesn't probably
when we get to about a month after the
uh writer strike ends that's when the
cycles
to make their deal yeah I spoke to
somebody today who's
um reasonably close to it
um they said they're not in the room but
they're like in the conversation
um they seem to think it's going well
for the actors yes
um and I said the personal advice
project says these Studios desperately
want this done by the first of November
and they're they're talking they said
they'll actually come back to it really
almost reasonable but the actors
um negotiating team have like succeeded
they've sort of backed off of a couple
of areas that the studio so the students
like okay if we can just both come out
of this with a bit of you know with a
bit of Pride sort of thing and yeah and
this doesn't cost us too much they're
basically told them what the red line is
this is this is how much money we're
willing to spend on this and no more and
this and the actors are sort of get into
the getting the sense of oh yeah okay we
need to be there needs to be a bit of
give and take it so I'm told that they
he says Friday we could get something
really really positive it's getting it's
getting close so we'll see see what
happens but obviously it's it only takes
one thing to disagree on and it can
throw it all out the window but he
seemed really confident AI
yeah apparently the AI thing's done
that's apparently that was agreed ages
ago
residual seems like it's the hard thing
it was the weird thing for writers I
don't know if you all seen the writer
stuff but it is it's a little funky it's
a little funky for on both ends I don't
think anybody's happy which tends to be
a good deal if nobody's happy uh
compromises as we met at that point yeah
yeah
so
we've got the game
we've got the movie 1994 movie
anniversary I think those are two big
points I I do wonder whether the the
planet is already in place I think
probably because of the game and because
of the you know and and these are the
things are coming up
I do think there's a problem that the
active strike is in place because they
won't have a lead in man so I think
we're only going to get an announcement
of we're doing it I don't think we'll
get anything more than that so I was
talking to
um I said this person that works very
close to the pr and I spoke to the um
person that works at the PR Company the
consults
and they said it's almost impossible for
them to do a big public
hurray
which will get me onto gateworld
right so today gate will have released a
story saying that look at New York
Comic-Con Amazon do have a two-hour big
slot and um they've teased I'll just
read what they've said
um
um join Prime video at New York Comic
Cons Empire stage for a special
presentation featuring exclusive first
looks and never before seeing footage of
returning fan favorite series and highly
anticipated new series
I mean Amazon gay world have took that
to me who Could That Be Stargate and and
yeah I mean why not it sounds it does
sound like it yeah
potentially yeah definitely
it's I'm it's almost certainly not it's
um it's going to be Amazon
TV shows it's going to be
um stuff that they'd already started
filming they're talking about that's
then got put on pause so I think is it
series four of the boys
the next one yeah
potentially bits of rings of the next
rings of power it's there's a couple of
other series as well that they've
basically already started to film and
they're planning to put the show little
sneak peeks off to get a bit of
excitement going it's going to be Amazon
TV shows and he says the important thing
this person I speak to today is
basically said I tell you what I've done
no none of my real job today
no I I'm a social worker I actually have
responsibilities
um
none of it okay
I wouldn't even know
um
I need you can I did my job properly I
have Break
um he's basically said the important
thing that's not mentioned there is it
doesn't say Amazon and MGM
okay that's what I say because do we do
we know if it's gonna actually be on
Prime have they like fully announced
it's going to be on prime or is it still
possibly an epicng Plus
the last time I I spoke to
um
the person that actually Matt kind of
knows that stopped talking to us because
she's they got a bit worried about their
job
um they were quite close to Michael
Wright and Michael Wright apparently
there was a screaming match he came out
of a meeting with a bunch of people from
Amazon and kicked a bin across the room
it was all Furious because he
wanted
Stargate franchise for MGM plus that was
always the plan and they were arguing
and this is one of the things Mark
Fergus was getting annoyed about with
Amazon at Christmas time
and because he was basically saying
where is this TV show going I need to
know where what you're planning to do
with it and what the rough budget's
going to be because that's I will then
tailor the show to what you actually
want me to do
um so if it's gone in MGM plus it ain't
getting 10 million dollars an episode
it's got a prime it might and I think it
wouldn't have been that much it would
have been more like seven I think 10
million is what he was asking for they
offered five I think they've agreed
somewhere in the middle but if it's MGM
plus you're getting four and that's it
sort of thing and so he just wanted to
know those answers
um
uh apparently though as well they were
so convinced that this was going this is
the MGM plus was building a lot of its
plans around Stargate
and actually like you know qualified
from a business point of view sort of
thing they were expecting to get this
big franchise and that's one of the
reasons why stuff because he wasn't
getting any promises
so at the moment
it really depends on what sort of level
Amazon decide to aim this at if they
spend eight nine million dollars an
episode it ain't going on an engine Plus
or not first anyway yeah
it'll go on Prime
the other thing is it does seem that all
of the new franchises and this we've
known this probably for a year now is
that Amazon have cut MGM out of it
and they're saying
um
this is why Brad Wright isn't involved
because Amazon have gone no we're doing
this
so MGM can carry on all the stuff it's
already doing but it ain't doing
anything new franchises anyway
so they're they're doing it themselves
they're keeping it internal so the
question is do Amazon consider Stargate
to be an Amazon Prime
commodity and in which case that's why
they've not mentioned MGM and why they
could maybe
announced at New York Comic-Con
I I think they are
looking at it as because they obviously
bought MGM yeah it just happens now
in that email they sent you they called
themselves Amazon pictures they didn't
say anything about Amazon and MGM
pictures it was Amazon pictures yeah so
that that tells you all you need to know
it's it's an Amazon pictures
um production produced by Amazon to be
fair they said at mpm and Amazon
pictures
they did say that in the email
at it I've got it I've got it written
down next to me at MGM and Amazon
pictures we try to create exciting and
new TV and movies
so they did you've got to remember as
well
they're absorbing so
Amazon own MGM MGM owns Stargate and
these companies merged as they were so
even though Amazon does control Stargate
and just makes all the decisions
they can't just release it as an Amazon
products because it's not it's an
important product
so there are some technicalities around
that
um but surely they can because all they
have to do is they have to ask
permission to themselves and they'll say
yeah and they can
I know it sounds black and white but it
isn't there's a merger agreement between
the two companies and that effectively
means Amazon owns MGM but it's more
complicated than that but but with
Amazon employees because all the MGM
employees got sacked or left so like it
is
[Music]
n't it
as a result talk a bit closer I don't
know why I'm doing that talk a bit
closer to your microphone
talk very close to your microphone for
me
I need to stop uh what were you saying
but
about the um the MGM deal
um that was well the agreement that was
uh the only reason why uh MGM even still
exists as an office isn't it
yeah they'd have probably gone yeah they
probably would have been liquidated by
now but um but yeah
um they've still got a world
headquarters in Hollywood and they still
own they still have massive staff but
um the staff was decreased significantly
after Amazon they just said basically
all the existing contracts were not
renewing them so
um
so right so talking to
um the internal person
they said there's basically
um five different things they think
about when doing an announcement like
this so they do an event release
a Comic-Con yeah they do just a press
release where they'll just release the
statement saying blah
um they may do a documentary so they'll
always think about oh is it a big thing
so for RoboCop there's probably going to
be a documentary that goes comes out
just before around the movie release
about the original movie and blah blah
um they will always look at doing things
like a re-release so can they get the
the original thing on DVD or Blu-ray or
4K can we do a 4K version for Prime can
we do something like that
um or
um oh and they always like to coincide
with some sort of anniversary or date or
something and so they'd like a reason to
announce on a day right so that's either
it could be Amazon day you know I want
to do the Amazon day um
Star Trek always announces stuff and
they've got like two or three
anniversaries Like a Star Trek day
Federation day and things like this and
they announced stuff on those days
so if we look at that I mean I think an
event release is reasonably unlikely
because they haven't got an actor
what do you it's the same question isn't
it what do you do
yeah for all this other stuff Amazon
Prime stuff that they've filmed a bit of
and they've had to go and pause they can
show they can get people excited because
they can show a bit of unseen footage
and set it in the statement unseen bits
for Stargate what do you do
that's that's where I'm I'm wondering
because if they can't even walk out with
a director
that that hurts that's that's it doesn't
necessarily hurt like just a general
announcement but it does lessen the
impact of it in a few different ways
where if they walked out maybe not guns
blazing with like a whole cast and crew
like look what we got we're ready we're
the second this is thing this strikes
over we're ready
that would be nice it's just not
applicable here and if they're not able
to even walk out there with a director
showrunner maybe if they had like an
executive producer walk out there if
they brought Brad Wright and like
yeah what what like Fergus or somebody
out there then that would be nice I
think that's the only way that it it
retains gravitas or not I I hate it we
live in a 24 7 News cycle it's going to
be gone within 24 hours if it's just a
simple little announcement we need
something with weight I think
as much as it sucks I heard someone
compare that that Punisher season two
whenever it was coming on Netflix
Punisher season one a lot of people
loved it it was amazing Punisher season
two really good but like it's the whole
Netflix model like if you put everything
out at once you have 24 hours to talk
about it 48 hours maybe and then
Southern news out everyone's binged that
entire season it's not that week to week
kind of thing and I guess it's kind of
similar in this sense where it's not
like a week to week but it just needs
that weight that uh just stays in our
mind you know we need that something to
linger I don't know if that would have
it besides just our general excitement
yeah all they need for an announcement
is a video
obviously it's just gonna be CGI at this
point but it would just be all they need
for running I'll get you back watch it
yeah
you can see the chevron's Locking
like we maybe see like three locking or
so and then whoosh
we expect them to make a big Stargate
announcement what they could do at New
York Comic-Con or they could just
release a video of everything they've
got coming they could just go Amazon
and then there's loads of stuff and one
of the things and then but then they'll
do it cryptically knowing that they will
go crazy what does this mean what does
this mean and all they ever do is show a
Chevron or show a gate or show a or
something and maybe they could do it
like that so they'll do like a with a
mysterious figure non-announcement sort
of thing yeah they'd be a smart like
jeez
yeah yeah like like you're looking from
the back side of the gate so you can
kind of see through it but you can't
make out who it is
yeah something like that yeah
if they were going to do something in
your comic and I think that's more
likely
than a big Stargate announcement that
they'll do something cryptic
and that's the sort of thing that these
sort of people love doing
um
so that that's possible and again if
that's what they were doing that's maybe
why Stargate isn't been involved in this
because that would have had to have been
done already
um
because it's next week
so just a little quick you know
yeah literally week on Friday so
um
but those things I think like saying not
having no actor I think makes it really
difficult to make a big
splashy Comic-Con thing but then what
they do is next year at San Diego
Comic-Con they have a big Stargate
panel oh yeah the director everybody
said have started filming and now no
people will come because of it anyway
because they've already pre-announced
something by then they could have a
replica of the new appearance of the
gate as a backdrop
itself
yeah
yeah and and actually by then they could
even have some early footage
they could even like show a few scenes
and things and make a big movement
that's that's what I make a big deal out
of it and it's coming I mean in a way
why make a big deal of it because it's
going to be at least two years away it
doesn't matter what you do people are
gonna you know the the we won't we'll go
crazy but other people will forget about
it within two days anyway amazing in a
way you may as well just do a press
release going yeah we are doing it we're
doing it
we uh
we won't shut up about it so there's
always going to be someone talking about
no matter what
so so
someone's going to hear something and
you know we're just going to go on and
on and on about it
yeah we've spoken about it for two years
already so another team we won't let
them forget
videos I've done the other day and it
made me sad
I've actually avoided to Target videos
for a while I've got to start doing them
though
yeah well I wish I hadn't
um I do worry sometimes I just talk
about this too much but then something
happened I go well I've got to talk
about that I'll just talk about this one
thing and then I won't talk about
anything I won't talk my story again for
a week at least a week and then some
awesome
pop into my brain and at least on video
yeah yeah yeah
um
Harris if we
um do
that thing that we were thinking about
with that thing that we were thinking
about
um it's exactly the same time as the New
York
um thing so when Amazon are on
stage doing their bits I think that he's
on about the thing when I was on Discord
to you and I got dead excited
yeah
and I have no idea what it is
we so we could be live I can't say
anything because it's not happening
to you and I was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah I'm
with you I'm with you I'm with you okay
I'm there well it could mean that we're
live in a very special place anyway
which would actually in a way annoy me
because I'm going to immediately go bye
person we're on with I'm going live on
sidetracks to screw this
in a very special place in all of your
hearts yeah exactly
there is still quite a lot of division
at Amazon and MGM though it seems like
it
um
it seems to me
um within MGM there's a big division
between
they don't really care if they do a TV
series or a movie but it's like Brad
Wright or not Brad right and that's the
division there's a there's a very small
group I've got a big group of very loyal
people that go well let's just do it
with Brad for the love of God and that
includes like Michael writing people
like that and then there's another side
of people going like no no the fresh
blood doing it with Amazon is doing this
way is a good idea let's do let's do
this and let's put let's just crack on
with it but with an Amazon more
alarmingly there is a division between
Stargate isn't well let's do star
against Argos great let's do the sleep
and dryer sci-fi but there is a group of
within Amazon that like Stargate isn't
big enough it's not popular enough
numbers it won't be as popular as they
think so
um a thousand times personally
well
numbers don't lie
yeah the the numbers are not there it's
the third largest sci-fi franchise and
sci-fi I mean the two biggest dirt
Giants you know and hey if it's the
sleeping giant it's still there it might
not be
an 80 foot tall giant like Star Wars or
Star Trek might be but it's like a 50 60
foot tall giant or something it's a big
one it's a big one it's definitely the
third at the Sci-Fi franchise it's
number three even now I've been on
screens for 12 years it's still the
Third and that's the big number because
it's the most expansive of all of them
Star Wars and Star Trek are the most
popular aren't they by numbers and
everything else yeah yeah yeah yeah well
according to Disney
[Music]
come here
let's poke Mickey
yeah you're lying about the nervous that
joke is good I'm enjoying the Joker
um
last night
[Music]
um
I've got to quite watching so surely the
character Beady character
last time I assume you're still alive
so he's not oh man well
if we don't okay we can give you a not
spoiler and it'll make it
anyway no we're talking Star Wars movie
anyway so don't don't worry about it
um this is a Stargate stream dammit
at least it's got star in it
Star is Born
I just want to ask you if you agree with
this by the way but um I said like in
the video when I when I was talking
about how all this was being done that
I've said it's 6.9 chevron's locked
um Dave who's one of the one of our
members because he says it's Chevron 6
is locked seven Chevron encoded do we
think that's probably where we're at
I think I thought it was quite a nice
way of putting it
that's where I hope we're at yeah and
then if if they like push it back
anymore we can say 717 will not engage
I'm eloping stuff it
um what do you guys think about this
those in generally though I mean does it
there's no smoke without fire
is that fair
I don't think I don't think we'd have
heard like the person who messaged us
and then subsequently the people you've
spoken to about all of this I don't
think we would have heard
what we heard had something not happened
so yeah even though I'm not worried 100
sure what it is
there's movement somewhere and there's
obviously enough movement so these
people actually find out so it's
probably further along than even they
know so I mean yeah I'm not worried
I mean as a result of the uh email you
got Jay I mean I got I've got a feeling
that they're shifting gears they're
moving further but
um
let's be too secretive
they don't want anyone to know a thing
about it like um like other stream
Services
they just
they're just being quite they're not
uh engaging us you know
now I'm not gonna they're gonna be koi
they are going to be coy yeah because I
I have to admit I have emails MGM
directly
and I just sort of said very nicely if
there is an announcement if you if you
give me a couple of hours heads up I
will have an amazing video
um ready and I will talk about it I will
big you all up and I will tell you how
lovely mgmodine and um you know we'll
I'll do my best for you I'm here for you
just tell me a few hours before and they
just emailed back thank you very much
I'll take that what they did is they
patted you on the head and shifted you
away
pretty much thank you
could have ignored my email altogether
because I knew it was cheeky to
beginning with I even started this is
cheeky and I know you can't say anything
what
can you at least confirm this yeah just
tell me it's coming let's do something
in suspense this is killing us
maybe
um well Amazon responded to you huh
technically
and sort of confirmed rumors to a degree
uh well definitely good movie I'm
serious
that yeah well there's got to be
something coming because I mean you
quoted it earlier and I was a little
cheeky in their comments which we'll go
back to a little bit but uh gateworld
just did a video and they literally
talked like my cheeky comment was that
they just did a bullet point of
everything that you've talked about for
the past about three or four months and
they've just bullet pointed it all in
one video yeah
even longer uh but really that just
seems like a my comment in there was a
double confirmation seems good for
Stargate you know and that's like two
confirmations they wait till things are
like official and insecure so to them
this is also secure which if they're if
they're waiting that long to put
something out and put it out with
confidence like that
okay we like to deal in rumors and we we
talk about things that happen for sure
but they they wait for a long time so if
it's if it's both of us I think David
from gateworld definitely has a
journalistic attitude with these things
he is very and if you read the article
that went with and you listen to the
video he's very very careful about what
he
the firmed sort of nice here we hear
this we hear that and he's very very
careful with it I wish he would throw in
the odd side track have been awesome but
you know they don't and they prefer not
to do that uh you did do that in the
comment though he responded and said put
all of this out first so I like Mark's
comment just now
what's up
oh
okay
so you need to pitch exactly the grocery
store he needs to pick a tent right
there
so
um Batman
um if if you want questions answered by
the way
um super chats
even though I'm gonna answer this one do
you prefer the theatrical as of
streaming movie you guys go what do you
think theatrical or streaming or
anything
personally I would watch streaming
because I already paid for it and I
don't have to spend anything extra
but because it's Stargate I would buy a
ticket to the theater so
guys but yeah I think I would prefer
streaming noven you go because I got an
ultimatum here
I would definitely prefer streaming but
if it's a cinematic movie then
you know I'd go to the cinema I'll pay
you the money I'd pay the good money to
go see it and I would take us and I'll
take a drill to take the seat home with
me afterwards
hahaha For The Memories you know
I've got a devil's advocate y'all come
on Cinema boy
if Amazon or MGM puts this on a
streaming service as a film if it's a
streaming movie and it's not an actual
film
say goodbye to Stargate it's not coming
back streaming movies first of all and
in our minds whether we because we I
mean we like streaming stuff like we'll
go hop on there we'll watch it still
have a good time with it nonetheless but
no matter who you are
connotatively your brain is like that
streaming movie is a TV movie which is
not the same quality
as an actual film it feels like they
don't care about it as much it would
feel like they didn't really put the
time and effort that they could have and
probably should have into it and it
would feel like a complete disservice to
Stargate and the fandom as a whole and
it's it would end up being a nothing
burger like the best streaming movies
that have come out in recent memory are
like extraction two
but you see any Netflix release how much
money they made off of that or how much
money they didn't make off of that
better probably said same thing with
Enola homes that was a big one right
that's one of your biggest movies from a
streaming movie standpoint
do you hear anybody talking about that
it didn't make them money we can
guarantee that you know
I I think it would bite Stargate
completely it would invite the head off
of Stargate there wouldn't be any
direction to go after that it might be
easier to toss a streaming TV show after
that but not as many people would and
maybe not as many people wouldn't want
it but it would it would be starting
with the bad taste at that point because
one of the things that petered out
Stargate in a lot of ways is the TV
movies I mean I'm coming from a
hindsight's 2020 perspective but if they
would have taken two or three more
months on each one of those TV movies
and put them in cinema
we would still be watching Stargate
wouldn't have left our TVs that was
definitely an economic thing about the
uh the thing about the TV movies is they
were basically the next seasons
got down to the movie
yeah that's why I felt last quality with
that
that way sorry the first TV movie was
just the finale of season 10 as well
yeah it was just the last two episodes
but DVD sales were brilliant at that
point so that's why they did it
but connotatively
right so Matt you say streaming but you
would go to cinema
what do you think the budget for
extraction 2 was Netflix's biggest movie
probably last year or this year
it's kind of decent huh
it was decent for streaming okay so okay
I'll give you a guess
55 million 65 million or 85 million
I was gonna get 70. I'm gonna get 65.
sorry go let's say 85. because you're
probably like say it say that's maybe 65
million
thank you Gary for the contribution but
stop it
um are we back to your DM soon promise
yes you you wanted to tell me something
what was it you want to tell me
um I forgot about that yes message to
say hi
um 65 million and that was their big
movie this year that was their big
summer movie this year 65 million for a
cinematic theatrical release
you know it was a good movie it looked
great as well
but it's it's the same thing as Punisher
48 hours it's out of your Zeitgeist you
lose it all
about it makes a good point that oh look
at um
pray
last minute they started thinking oh
pray this is good should we put it in
cinemas and it was very quickly they
were like
we can't we've done it wasn't that um
they didn't want to Disney was just like
whether it's so the director and stuff
were like no this has been we've done
everything for streaming we've done
everything for the small screen we can't
but it'll look [__] if we put up the
cinema we're gonna have to spend another
30 million dollars because we're gonna
have to redo all over the CGI it'll look
terrible
we can't do it
and that was the main reason why then
Disney when they were looking at it and
all the early test screens are doing
great it why it didn't where they didn't
divert into the cinema and it was just
because they just knew it would look
awful
and it it it's different when it's to
the cinema it just is
but put it this way
if if this is a streaming movie and we
get a budget of 50 million that would be
amazing
and to be honest that would be a quite a
big budget for streaming movie
it goes to the cinema and they they do
it from the beginning they say it's
going to be a cinema movie will get a
budget of more like 90. 80 18 90 million
dollars
which is a Creator I don't know if you
have seen that or not just yet but the
Creator was made for 80 million dollars
and it is it's the best looking film of
this year way more so than like Fast X
that spent 350 million dollars or any
Marvel movie that spent 205 200 300
million dollars whatever
80 million wouldn't be bad 90 million
would be bad if they have someone like
I mean they could they could hire Gareth
Edwards as director I wouldn't I
wouldn't be mad but
someone capable of holding back I guess
and and putting the budget into place is
required I guess is the best way to say
that that's what we need we need
something that's going to look that
they're going to have to have if it goes
to theater though they're going to have
to have the big CGI sequences the big
action sequences it's gonna have to be a
theater movie if it's a streamy movie on
the flip side of this argument
we might get something that feels more
like Stargate
we don't necessarily need
they don't need to go as far with it
if that makes sense but a story
see I agree with you there
it's just
they want a new audience and that's not
how you get a new audience that's how
you get your old audience to come in and
be really excited and they would have
all of us there and I I wouldn't say I'm
not excited for that at all because I'd
be pumped but that's not how you get a
new audience
maybe a new audience over the next
decade but they want money now which is
going to keep fueling these projects
continuously so
I think they think they need
it
so much
as long as you keep saying hire a Harris
Amazon please
yeah you just want to hire Harris so you
can fire him
yeah hey as long as you send me a couple
paychecks I'll be happy for a little bit
presidential yeah fired have you said
anything about pay
good point you would turn up for like
sandwich money
can I have something for Coke
no problem yeah
I got invited to my second Comic-Con
um about three weeks ago
I don't no it's next summer and it's in
Quebec
okay so I just said
um do you know I'm based in Britain and
they're like oh no no sorry we didn't
I'm so sorry about that um would you
would you be interested in unless
my expenses would be significant and
they're like oh
we deliver lunch
maybe pick you up from the airport if
you're lucky I think this is like a
YouTuber's panel and so it's just like
no no I'm sorry I'd love to but no I'm
sorry I'm not I'm not flying to Quebec
for an afternoon
um but but thank you so much for
thinking it's the second time my other
thoughts Albuquerque I think it was
Albuquerque I think it was an
Albuquerque
that's where Saul's from well yeah there
but again I'm not going down
what's not going so why can't I get
invited one in Britain for the love of
God you don't just want to be invited to
the Comic-Con you want to be invited to
host the Comic-Con well I'd sit on a
panel happily not a host it
we'll stop yeah I might have to stay at
yours if I'm going to Quebec for the
Comic Con and if seriously if you put
any more money on that thing
I we're going to fall out and I'm going
to block yeah have you noticed each time
it's got lower and lower yeah yeah
actually
He Loves Us less that she did initially
no problem you can't do a 50 piece
actually I've not got no no okay forget
I said that because I know what she'll
do now forget I said yeah yeah no I um
if there's anything
um you wish so
um
um yeah I can't get I can't get one in
London or you know Birmingham or
something or as a Comic-Con 10 Mile it's
like 12 miles from my house
I can't get invited that but I'll get
invited to Albuquerque anyway
the one in Telford like soon
arrange your own it's the Welsh
Comic-Con even though it's in England
so when they do the SGU Comic-Con
specifically for SGU in Telford
are you going dressed up as Colonel
Telford
no I'm going in charge I'm going to host
it oh okay all right come on I will go
and just do all the health and safety
stuff
um
so theatrical movie or or or streaming
movie then there's like the the idea of
like the change in budget the fact that
it is hasn't got quite the same oomph
behind it does that change your mind
Melvin or Matt about what you'd prefer
to see
no no
see I think the higher the budget of the
movie
the better the quality the uh set pieces
we're going to get for the show
and I think that is probably the best
reason for them to do a synatic movie in
the first place
to set stuff up to get the SGC yeah
whatever happens on the cinema will
bleed into the series don't we so that's
what seems to be the idea anyway
yeah well it's going to act as the pilot
episode anyway for any new show
so
um
for me the only downside of a thing is
the theater releases it'll take about
six months longer
we'll have to wait a bit longer that's
basically downside
didn't didn't they uh actually say that
the show will be soon after the movie
released
so
it could be in matter of a couple of
weeks maybe a few months after movies
released that we get the first episode
I think the movie would stream I think
they'd go to cinema and then about six
months after that we could get the
series and right
Banner
right how do I Banner
Harris is
okay we really do appreciate it thank
you very much please seriously
maybe you should start you should
actually set up a banner that says Kerry
stop super chain yeah you've already
supported loads Kerry we really really
appreciate everything you already do for
the channel
thank you so much all you other people
don't do anything
just look at Karen Terry's like the best
person ever I'm just saying yeah she's
lovely so one of the top three
top three people yeah ever three of us
here
so one of us is okay whatever
your mom and your dad and so what you're
saying is you like Kerry much more than
you like all of us
that's what you're saying
I plead the fifth that's in this country
um that girl you were sleeping with
mostly
I didn't think of that I was gonna mock
him for something she's
um anyway the fifth doesn't work in the
UK so you're outnumbered
um in this country if you don't say
anything that you then rely on later
I'm not joking don't do it again
I can't give it you back
it's just up and all you're actually
doing is getting YouTube loads and stop
stomachs
don't do it again
um thank you so so much don't do it
again
I'll I'll just all give it to charity if
you keep doing it
um and I'll give it to account one of
the points of doing it yeah she hates
um
that's a question that's a great
question regardless of Kerry H is
Canadian she loves everybody
[Music]
like Nazi party retirement fund is that
I think no it's not
they're retired then they're not Nazis
anymore right
no that's a conundrum good point
just saying
um we hate Canadians charity funds
Canadians
we only hate the Canadians that think
they're French
oh yeah the French Canadian so we could
I'm sure there's some weird the ones in
Quebec watch out that's another reason
why I can't go to quebecue
I what's that joke I think we mentioned
a couple weeks other joking
I only hate two things
intolerance and the belgiums or the
French anyway
um
RDA is a Canuck
Mega yes and we love him as well
um yes we do we do love MacGyver
don't ask for beer money thank you very
much
um and whenever we do these lives I want
beer money they want whiskey money
um
I got drunk when I was about 19 on a
bottle of Jack Daniels I can't even
smell it now
I think I mean the vomiting was
projectile and I can't even smell it I
really struggle
foreign
[Music]
gonna beat Gary yeah
thank you Kerry so so much we really
appreciate it but you can just put
comments on and I'll put them up from
now on okay
um so
where do we feel we are how confident
are we do you think tell me what
what's that confidence for New York
Comic-Con
um
yeah maybe
I mean I'd I'd prefer if it was because
it's gonna be like on the world stage
kind of like it'll get videoed it'll get
clipped it'll go viral on the internet
so I kind of hope that but out of seven
chevronson come on we'll score out seven
how many Chevrons confidence are you
that's it
first sorry for New York I'm coming
Wormhole oh for New York Comic-Con uh
okay five
really like that's high
yeah because I think there's a very good
chance it could happen and I'd like it
to
me but
I don't know as long as it sounds on
this month I don't care
I just wanted to
out of seven out of seven I couldn't
really gauge you like that because um I
invited you here for exactly this point
you're ruining the whole video you'll
never return
I wasn't giving you a choice this is the
[__] democracy
this is
not a dictator and this is not a
democracy this is a dictatorship and I
am yourself we're a time when a first
Chevron doesn't look there you go does
that work
no just pick a number between one and
seven
yeah
one then one Chevron for New York Comic
Con yeah one Chevron oh it's too soon
they haven't you know with the uh right
strike in the sack after strike there's
there's not been enough time for them to
really do anything to set anything up
they can all they can talk about the
stuff that they had in production or
were working on before but
during the strike when everything
started picking up speed and then uh we
had to wait so I don't think it's going
to happen so soon
no way
yeah
how about you Harrison
um
for for New York I'd either say
okay for I'd either give it a four out
of seven and then give
uh Amazon Prime day October 13th 14th a
three out of seven or I'd give it a
three out of seven for the New York and
a two out of seven for Prime day I'm
just I'm indecisive between those two
but they're within a few days of each
other as well to be fair so they're like
three days apart or something so I I
think it'll be the the SAG strike ending
that's really the the
that thing and and even with because I'm
with you Melvin they don't necessarily
have a whole bunch of things that can
jump out there with and I think it would
hurt them if they jumped out there too
much and didn't have that weighted thing
but I like what Matt was talking about
earlier like if they just tease
something and that's why I think the the
Amazon day would be almost as applicable
as New York Comic-Con if they're just
teasing something like just just seeing
a little Chevron
light up real quick like
then that's more applicable they don't
have to actually like say like it's
coming back but they don't actually have
to say the words for us kind of deal and
everyone looking down the sound of a
Chevron looking as they walk on stage oh
yeah
to hit the ground running to get the
momentum right after the strike I was
just gonna say the New York Comic on
there would you be a little bit more
confident if they just did not an
announcement
but the teaser would you feel that was
more
you just feel like that's what you're
saying anyway I'm sending Kerry a
t-shirt now damn it you paid for a
t-shirt
I don't care I I I would say if there's
an announcement or whether they just
tease something I'd say that's a bit
different I I would argue I'm maybe like
three chevrons for like an announcement
but I'd give like four Chevrons for them
to say that they could tease something
I'd read a little if they're going to do
something I believe that a little bit
more
um because of what's
been set up I think they could go 2024
Amazon Prime boom and then it'll be like
RoboCop a little bit a bunch of other
stuff we've probably never heard of and
don't care about and then there'll be
and there'll be some sort of Stargate
thing in mixed in there and it'll
they'll just and then that'll be it
lights down end of the thing
I could see that working and then yeah
that'd make everybody go crazy over
um thingy yes Kerry I will send you a
shirt
um keep calm and watch and watch star
game Draw that one we'll talk about it
later
um would Gary prefer a shirt or a hoodie
shut up she doesn't paint that okay
I've seen it
yeah
um they're not cheap so um that's not my
fault by the way I actually make
virtually no money on all that
merchandise I put it like the minimum
price they say like sell it at this
money and I'm like and make like 11 a
thing and I'm like I probably should
because I would have made some money off
the merch
um but instead I try and get it like I
make like two dollars if everything is
sold
um
just find a printing company who will
print all the shirts and the hoodies and
then we sell their map profit and it'll
be wages
when Stargate gets announced I'm going
to do something where
um
naked
yes no really that's when we hit 100 000
subscribers
um
it will be the quickest 100 Pages zero
you've ever seen
the channel banned instantly
oh they got my belly button out Matt did
that oh we're fine
um Sidetrack underwear put the uh put
the gate on them no
stop now no
no
don't mention that part no but I will I
will do
um something though with merch and stuff
and and and and do something that's a
bit because it's great to do to
Teespring because it's really easy on my
part I can do a design I could put it
out there and it's great
um but I I think I'm gonna do when it
gets announced I might do something yeah
or I'll maybe print off a bunch give
them away
um or something to celebrate that's
finally been freaking announced
um but we'll
will do something yeah Dave B just went
there and I'm not doing it I'm not doing
it
I'm just no we've already plugged the
merch enough
Okay so
comic so Announcement by Christmas
Are we more confident about that
yeah
like an announcement announcement or
just uh no it's happening I actually
think if they do a teaser at New York
Comic Con we'll get a proper
announcement within about a week or so
anyway because they'll they've basically
said it and then they will release
the boring statement of when and blah
blah blah and they'll have to start
doing that anyway because they'll have
to start thinking about
stuff will stop paying on IMDb
yes so they'll have no choice
we're forgetting
that
the um source that I speak to over at
one of the major talent agencies
seems to think
what at least what a director was being
signed up to something this week and
he's sure it was Amazon and he thinks
it's MGM
pretty sure it's Amazon
to get that done because they're gonna
drag him out in front of San Diego
Comic-Con I actually I don't think
that's the case but that it could be
um
I'm with you that makes sense but I I'm
not necessarily on like the the train
where if it's not announced by
New York Comic-Con that will get it by
Christmas I think by then you might as
well let it go into the New Year let
these things that have kind of like lost
their place with the strikes kind of
going on let that kind of pass let all
that kind of happen and then mid late
January early February early March
something like that after that first
quarter's done
Stargate takes hold kind of deal and
that way they might actually have more
to announce more people to walk out
there with
this is something to work
I don't know
holidays is a great time to announce
things of course but they're also
chock-full of
so many different things going on where
no matter what you announce in that time
it's going to be diluted just from the
sheer amount of everything going on in
that time period And in that November
December type of season earlier might
just be a good thing to like all right
well now there's nothing going on what
could there be
oh here's some Stargate and you know
yeah
I just think I I'm I think Stargate is
in a funny position for Amazon because I
mean how do they announce rings of power
that was just that was just a statement
wasn't it I mean they didn't
they didn't do a big stage thing for
that and that's the biggest thing
check this out it cost us billions yeah
but they're literal announcers like we
just spent 1.2 bill
series
it appeared in their financials
basically if they had no choice but
admit they were doing it and it but it
wasn't done on stage with a thing it was
done just through announcements
I'm not sure Amazon in the past have
ever done the big on stage announcements
for anything really except maybe this
Boys season two I think they did
one of the comic cons
um I remember them having all the actors
on the stage for some for that but I
don't think that was the first season
um
I'm not even sure they did for the
second because I think it would have
been June covered
so anyway my point is I don't think
Amazon have done a lot of that in the
past
but you I I'm kind of on the thought
process that they might have to and they
kind of realize that too after rings of
power because letting it just get
announced in the way it did immediately
let people's brains just go awry and
they didn't necessarily they they never
had the time to take control of the
narrative after getting it they're like
all right well we're spending a ton of
money on it and then everyone's like oh
you're spending money on Lord of the
Rings like good for you what about story
and we got what we got yeah yeah
just made a point there that and that
that brings me back to the emails I've
had off MGM and that is what rings of
power did they did this through
influencers and YouTube channels they
tried to get a load of YouTubers on side
and it backfired quite badly
and then they email me
and it's like and I I don't know if
gateworld and other people have had
emails but I imagine they will at some
point
um
so maybe that's what they're doing again
and but it didn't work rings of power
but rings of power is a different
magnitude Stargate I we all the door
star get here the rings of power thing
is
a Ringo power isn't that
they won't spend anything like them but
the problem is when councils as well the
problem was the way it got announced
they announced that one billion quid
thing and they never got away from that
all of them
that won't happen with Target again yeah
that was the narrative
that was always a problem
example of budgets killing things
um and I don't think that's going to be
the problem if anything it goes either
way but guys
thank you so so much for the the for
coming on on a Wednesday evening when
you've all been at hard at work and um
things and uh obviously not me I've just
been emailing people all day so people
might have died
um and that's what I do
sorry I'll just email people that's all
I do yeah that's I do mostly as well
pain in the neck I say if you when you
care as little about people as I do it's
uh it's quite I shouldn't have gone into
this job I shouldn't be like a big man
or something
it was a mistake
so when you're a heartless monster like
me
um
I love people [__] you guys
nobody's like Jamie but you're so nice
like you care about people
I plead the fifth
anyway
[Laughter]
thank you Matthew
yeah
I'm sorry um
[Music]
I also noticed that when you you haven't
got a shirt on your merch that actually
says shut up Matt
and we did design one didn't we but I
couldn't get it on the damn shirt right
thing and that designed a really nice
one but it didn't fit in the shirt right
so I couldn't use it and then I forgot
about it
but if no shirts we just need mugs so
then you can just raise it to the camera
I will I need to get at the very least
the team a a short map mug someone's egi
something on this
perfectly what we're gonna do is have
some mug and then it's gonna just have
the words
about
oh dear what I thought this is my
message is cut but it's the biggest one
we know so I like it
I've got a picture
massive more guy this bit it's a Harris
would love it because it's enormous I
can barely lift it is it a sports direct
mark yeah I love my sports direct look
um enough time of course electron's
Broken it's just a Union Jack on there
but it's in fact the size of my head
it's amazing
um I think we have a short amount on one
side and a butt plug on the other side
[Music]
I'm not having my name on anything with
butt plugs no
is that the Box
Davey thank you so much like always
appreciate hard work days to put in
every day thank you so much yeah I mean
literally people in my hometown died
today because I couldn't be asked to do
my job properly
but I'm here for you to talk about
Stargate
um
so that's the important thing they did
in Texas
disciplinary at work so he can't now
join us
and the evidence against it
um failed t-shirt slogans you can enter
my gate anytime well I did send
um
Shelly God thank you so Jesus Christ I
feel so bad that um yeah through the
orifice joke forgetting she doesn't
actually like Stargate and I know glue I
was talking about so she thought I was
just sending her a slogan about her
orifice
um
no [__] clue
she wasn't totally wrong with it though
which was hilarious
that's quite good
um Stargate underwear with his puddle
jumper guys
let's go fiddle Jim from the back
once more through the old orifice that's
what I said that's what was on it anyway
at least
thank you so so much and we'll be back
on Sunday at some point to talk Star
Wars I am at the Caravans who might be a
bit late guys if you don't mind
um but I'll let you know on the day
um
great friend of the channel I think I
can announce this um Jenny stiven is
going to be on the channel in a couple
of weeks
um it was hopefully going to be next
week but
she's a busy lady she's going to be
it'll be within a couple of weeks we're
hoping we might be able to announce
something quite exciting this week but
we'll see
um if it happens it pulls off other than
that
yep
um what
I don't know
um so yeah so we got we've got some good
stuff coming up there anyway so good
good stuff coming up for the next few
weeks and then if starger gets announced
immediately message me because I will go
live immediately
um because you know it's going to get
announced either when I'm asleep or not
at my phone it's funny
I checked my phone I'm so paranoid at
the moment I check my phone constantly
waiting for comments it's it's happened
it's happened it's happened and
um and obviously it hasn't yet but I
just know the second I'm away from my
phone for five minutes this weekend I'll
be off my phone virtually the whole
weekend it's bound to happen you need a
pair of them
smart glasses that linked to your phone
you've got the little heads up display
in constant stream of like news and
it'll be so much it'll be so much better
for the menu games as well
good man I hope we should be walking out
of traffic swear words people will be
walking past me going to just call me
I'm just watching the football score but
um anyway guys no seriously thank you so
so much
um we are going to talk about Star Wars
show Jerome at the weekend on Sunday
where we'll be talking Star Wars
[Music]
um
you want me
I said Laura is correct though totally
correct I will be another uh when it
happens he'll be he'll be on the blue or
he'll finally have a commode
yes
I I read that's when I read all my
stories and things so if it happens when
I'm on the loot I'll know instantly I'll
be online within like two minutes if
it's if it happens when I'm not on the
lose the problem
I'm like
because I've been reading about Stargate
and you leave me alone I'm on the toilet
I love being there anyway guys thank you
so much let's say good night
um
actually we had we had over 100 people
watching us at one point this evening
which is brilliant I'm so glad that you
guys keep coming back to talk to us by
Stargate and we will oh and Melvin thank
you so much for your first
um live you've been absolute Legend
thank you very much sir great um we will
definitely have you back and even though
the comment section has been a bit light
because you've been missing but if you
could next time make comments well even
without me they'd mention the BPS
thank you very much and then we were
going to do some polls today but I got
so excited about everything I forgot
we'll do it next time
and then yeah yeah well I forgot but
thank you so much everybody and um
say everybody we'll see you next week
adios
ciao foreign
[Music]